[Music]
there are some things you just
can't live without
like gravity
oxygen
the sun's warmth
and we're about to take those vital
things away from you
but just for five seconds don't worry
[Laughter]
just how horrifying would those five
seconds be
which missing thing would be the worst
to deal with
[Music]
and would your life ever be the same
when those life supporting things came
back
this is what if and here's what would
happen if these five things disappeared
for five seconds
okay we'll start big and remove the
enormous scorching ball of gas that
makes our planet habitable the sun
you might think it would suddenly become
very cold but it wouldn't
you wouldn't even notice the difference
our planet has stored enough heat in its
atmosphere and oceans to keep us warm
for those five seconds without the sun
but if our star suddenly vanished from
the sky
things would get much worse than a
little temperature drop
the sun is the most massive object in
the solar system
it not only keeps us warm here on earth
but it has a massive gravitational
influence in space without the sun
every planet moon and asteroid in our
galactic neighborhood would start flying
off into outer space
okay this part gets a little confusing
but stay with me here now the moment the
sun disappears the entire solar system
would plunge into chaos
now even though the sun has vanished
you are still able to see it in the sky
as if nothing happened
this is because it takes the sun's light
eight minutes to reach us on earth
so you'd get this delayed effect of
seeing the sunlight when the sun is
already gone
five seconds later the sun would return
to its original position and its gravity
would grab a hold of all the planets
again
they'd stop heading off into outer space
and return to orbiting the sun as usual
then 8 minutes and 15 seconds later
you'd see the sun blink for 5 seconds
but you'd most likely be busy trying to
survive all the gravitational havoc
losing the sun might have caused in
those five short seconds
the earth wouldn't travel far enough to
leave the habitable zone but
we don't know how this massive change in
gravity would affect our solar system
all right let's try this again maybe
with something less dramatic
how about removing all the oxygen for
five seconds
i mean you could just hold your breath
right
well this might surprise you but five
seconds without oxygen would be fatal
for you and the earth
at first you'd feel your ears burst
that's because the air pressure would
suddenly drop by 21
oh that would be painful
as soon as you recover from your pain
you'd see that all the concrete
buildings had turned to dust
that's because concrete sticks together
thanks to carbon dioxide
this molecule consists of one carbon and
two oxygen atoms
without oxygen nothing would hold the
concrete in those structures together
airplanes would fall from the sky
because there would be no combustion in
their engines
and all the water on the planet would
vanish too and hydrogen would flood our
atmosphere
but worst of all without oxygen your
body would be filled with hydrogen gas
and rupture
even if the planet could eventually
recover from these five seconds of
horror you wouldn't have a chance of
surviving it
[Music]
okay not having oxygen would be bad but
what about carbon
you already know that all the concrete
buildings would collapse but could you
survive without it
well the short answer is no
the long answer is that you'd
immediately lose 10 to 14 kilograms of
your body mass
that's because 18 of you is carbon
but it's not the kind of weight you'd
want to lose
carbon forms proteins carbs and fats and
it's a building material for your dna
without carbon your primary body
functions would just stop for five
seconds
but you wouldn't have to worry about
long-term effects
that's because the earth which has a
very carbon-based core and mantle would
collapse on itself
and
no you wouldn't survive this scenario
either
okay how about we try something more fun
like gravity who needs it anyway
imagine people cars and everything not
attached to the ground flying around
well the only downside is
you'd be flying in strong winds
i'm talking winds so strong they would
be six times more destructive than
hurricane katrina
and after five seconds of that you'd
plunge to the ground
at the same time the sun would lose its
gravitational grip on us in space
the earth would once again go flying in
a straight line at 30 kilometers a
second until the sun catches it again
well that wasn't so bad was it
those winds could really get much worse
like if we made the earth stop rotating
for five seconds
if earth came to a standstill our
atmosphere would keep moving thanks to
inertia
and this would make winds strong enough
to rip earth's crust apart the winds
would be most powerful at the equator
because of the earth's bulging shape
making water flow away from the equator
toward the poles and
that would cause massive
tsunamis but things would start going
back to normal after those horrifying
five seconds
the winds would die down and the water
would return to where it was
flooding everything in its way once
again
after so much destruction there might
not be much left on earth
you'd be lucky to survive this and if
you did
you'd have to spend the rest of your
life rebuilding the planet
it could be that after all these
disastrous scenarios the earth wouldn't
be suitable for life anymore
well then we'd need to start planning
humanity's global evacuation
but you know what
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]
you